bien julien le plus dur reste à venir
parce que c'est un garçon bien élevé
jamais un mot plus haut que l'autre
j'aime un gros mot dans les chansons
jamais jamais je viens est un type très
correct donc on va vous faire une
interview mauvaises langues
alors je suis bien je vais vous demander
quelque chose d'encore plus difficile
que ce que vous venez de faire c'est
dire du mal des gens alors on va
commencer très facile on va commencer
avec saddam hussein avait bien trouvé
une saloperie à dire sur lui une salle
privée c'est pas difficile non c'est
l'impression qu'il allait très mauvais
goût là quand j'ai vu ces panels voilà
peut-être trop loin déjà non mais je
vais surveiller tonton langage parce que
les gens je me lâche un peu regarde je
me lâche ce soir alors une méchanceté
vraiment sur ben laden je viens je sais
que ça peut d'ici samedi
ben laden ben laden il faut qu'il fasse
attention là l'air malade
ça m'avait fait j'avais été bon on va
plaire on va me faciliter un plus que
les choses soient méchancetés sur hitler
et méchanceté cinéma janvier non ils
méchancetés sur hitler
ça c'est pas dur alors y'en a plein de
méchanceté a trouvé méchancetés sur les
quais un petit beat au number je sais
pas pourquoi vous avez connu eva braun
non j'ai pas coller la brawn mais on a
des on a des bouquins qui nous explique
qu'effectivement il avait des problèmes
sexuels c'est pas bon non médical à
demain ça peut expliquer le reste quand
même non j'essaie de vous aider mais en
vidant vers la pologne qui ride on en
trouve ça
non mais c'est pas drôle bien non alors
il méchancetés sur hitler basse et plus
grands bourreaux de l'histoire voilà
alors maintenant monter un petit peu on
dirait une méchanceté sur patrick bruel
mais j'en suis sûre patrick bruel
et en plus je savais que ce serait
terrible et je le vois bien aux besoins
parce que je vais chanter avec lui je
vais pas trop engagé je vais médias fo
qui maigrissent un peu voilà très bien
médiateur dans les idées l'intérieur
cette fois gignac et vous prenez
toujours notre site notre fructose la
regarder yamina sa mission comme à la
ville et tout le monde moi c'est de la
course et les capotes cette année cap at
il a fallu que pèse toujours des
aliments ça fait du bien évidemment
alors on continue guy bedos une
méchanceté
guy bedos moi je dirai rien comment la
nuit dix ans à le réconcilier le méchant
je supplie peu gauche préfère les
sketches de jeu que jean loup dabadie
lui écrivait que les revues de presse
dakhla voilà ta font là mais tu connais
pas eu lieu à las pour lui c'est
terrible si l'épreuve de chanter les
morceaux qu'il ne sait rien
christophe dechavanne qui est obligé de
faire le ménage dans le loft à leu leu
nice people de tf1 la structure
julien un truc concia ce qu'est ce que
veut dire pâques
qu'est ce que tu veux dire paris n'a
fait le ménage dalet a pas vu passer
l'aspirateur un bond est allé passer
l'aspirateur une semaine mais on ne
passe pas très bien
alors ça c'est trop méchant loire dont
il ya une époque où il y avait un truc
était un peu systématique c'est qu'il
aimait bien surfer pipi dessus par des
animaux dans une nouvelle émission oui
oui si c'est assez méchant parce que si
tu dis qu il s en priver ça devient
méchant non non moi je connais pas en
privé c'est peut-être pas diffusé
d'événements je suis pas des
professionnels comme vous et moi de très
méchant méchant tu sais c'est alors
attention attention luc ferry une
méchanceté sur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale luc ferry il va
couler non méchant ça oui pour un ferrer
gilles belzons de série à la dérive je
ne lis plus les riches chinois est
méchant avec luc ferry alors qu'est ce
que je pourrais dire une très grande
méchanceté méritent ils vraiment la
jolie femme qui l'a a alors vu que je
veux dire quoi zapping assurer un truc
julien êtes des emplois oui
cette campagne avait ajouté la balle est
violent d'après ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est que moi je
il m'arrive de déjeuner ou de dîner avec
lui assez souvent avant j'espère qu'il
prendra sa très bien méritée prendra ça
pour un comme un hommage mais donc donc
ce jeudi la section baffie et moi y'a
plus rien d'autre à dire tu as dit qu'on
était des [ __ ] voilà qui résume bien
c'est pas mal maintenant mesdames
messieurs difficile hammam il reste le
plus difficile de tous pour julien clerc
julien vous êtes prêts vous allez me
dire du mal
julien clerc de guillaume durand votre
ami du mannequin guillaume durand votre
grand ami guillaume durand bah ouais je
pense que avec le bon service qu'il est
au tennis il devrait arrêter de me
servir mon coup droit qui est mon
meilleur temps est beau c'est d'essayer
de plus chercher mon revers cela dit
même avec ça il me badd c'est
désespérant et en tant qu'animateur the
vines je le trouve très bon en tant que
les maths et les meilleurs joueurs de
tennis
m
roger
c'est pas bien
oui
premier
m